hey guys in this video we're going to
talk about how to reduce bloating
quickly if your bloating not only does
it look like you have belly fat but it's
very uncomfortable it prevents sleeping
and you can't fit in your clothes so
there's some real simple things you can
do number one acupressure acupressure is
basically you're pressing instead of
using needles you're pressing on
different parts of your body now the
where you want to press is you want to
press underneath your right ribcage
right here take your hand and press into
it and hold that for two minutes what
are you doing you're kind of massaging
your your gallbladder and that will help
reduce all that congestion in there and
you'll you'll feel less bloated because
the gallbladder stores something called
bile VI lae and that's where the what's
helps you digest the fats and if you're
deficient in bile or it's the
gallbladder sluggish you will get
bloating when you eat okay
then you want to press on the other side
right through and here because you got
the gallbladder on the right side and
the left side you have the pancreas so
the pancreas is the other digestive
gland that helps you make the enzymes to
digest all these foods so everything
time you eat your body set your pancreas
senses what you eat and it generates
certain enzymes to help break that down
so if you run out of certain enzymes
you're going to get blow different
because the pancreas is not doing this
job and you're going to feel just
bloated so you want to work on the left
side as well so you have two minutes on
the right two minutes on the left boom
you feel less bloated but but of course
we want to fix the diet because this is
only temporary the next time you eat
comes right back so this gives you
temporary relief and now we want to
avoid the true deeper root causes of
bloating the common ones are the grains
and that would be the breads pasta
cereal crackers biscuits waffles
pancakes
so does juice alcohol things like that
the sugars but especially gluten gluten
is in the it's the protein in the grain
it just creates a lot of bloating for
people and then people say I'm gluten
free but you're still doing the grains
so they do tend to create bloating now
sugars especially combined with protein
so if you're doing some hamburger with
the bun and the fries
and the soda or the hot dog with the bun
you know and the carbs oh my gosh you
are going to get a massive spike of
insulin and massive bloating so let's
say you go to a Chinese restaurant what
do you get sweet-and-sour chicken which
is breaded so anything that you combine
protein and sugar is really really bad
for bloating and then also like what
about all the bars like the energy bars
or protein bars what do they have in
them sugars so you want to read labels
and make sure that you just keep the
sugars to a zero a minimum and and
that's really the danger of the
combination and also fat with sugar will
really increase insulin to more than
eating them separate so that would be
like let's say you have a doughnut
that's deep fried or some deep fried I
don't know
french fry they coat it with sugar but
mainly the the doughnut I will guarantee
if you have a deep fried doughnut that's
all the sugar and fat and it's sweet and
it's it's oily and you eat that you're
going to bloat I guarantee that's going
to happen so and the starches so we got
the the rice potato things like that
those are foods that will bloat you and
of course you can do too much protein as
well so again we want to reduce those
common things and then at the same time
let's say you reduce them and you still
have a problem then we have to increase
your acid in your stomach especially if
you have acid reflux
why because acid reflux is caused by not
enough acid and people take anti acids
oh my gosh they just screw everything up
so we want to increase the acid we won't
increase the bile B I L E which helps you
digest fat so the way I do it is I use
the apple cider vinegar plus this has
something called a concentrated outside
of vinegar tablet so you can swallow it
before a meal like two to three before
meal and it has something else called
betaine hydrochloride which basically
builds up your acids in your stomach
okay so this is really important and
then the gallbladder formula this has
some purified bile salts you take it
after you eat just one take two or three
before one after it's just going to help
you and then the bile also has in there
a lot of other things as enzymes it has
things to help the gallbladder
and it's a combination that is really
good for bloating to correct the problem
a lot of people are happy with that so
so yes we want to give you some
temporary relief we want to change the
diet and we might need to use nutrition
if it doesn't go away all right I will
see you in the next video